let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
why don't we start with our caller from
the 4 1 0 area code caller from 4 1 0
we've got a slightly different phone
system today can you hear me can we hear
you let's start with that yes I can hear
you
awesome what's your name where are you
calling from and feel free to go right
into your question alright my name is
Matt I'm calling from Baltimore and I
wanted to ask you a question about
academic ethics and gum you're a
professor now right I've noticed that
there's been a lot of academic pundits
around who have kind of been talking
outside of their areas of expertise and
I don't necessarily want to get into
people like Jordan Peterson who or maybe
arguably within their realm but someone
like Brett Weinstein recently has been
kind of going on a lot about postmodern
philosophy and all that sort of stuff
whereas he seems to have no background
in this whatsoever and I just kind of
wanted to get your opinion on you know
whether it's appropriate for a biology
professor to be giving lectures on
postmodern philosophy well listen here's
the thing there's sort of two answers to
this right there is no doubt that some
of these sort of celebrity professors
who do something that goes viral
all of a sudden they start speaking out
about whatever and and and it's not
their area of expertise at the same time
I don't want to be sort of that elitist
elitist leftist who says unless you have
formal education at the highest level
then you can't speak publicly on a
particular issue right so I think it's
important to just analyze each person
individually and say well are they
making sense and we can take their
credentials into consideration I don't
think someone should be banned from
speaking you know if a school wants to
invite and Brett Weinstein has been
speaking a lot at schools being invited
the school wants to invite Brett
Weinstein to speak about whatever right
astronomy I mean whatever it is if
that's what they want to do when they
believe there's an audience for it then
hey all power to them but I think it's
it's sort of incumbent upon the consumer
of those speeches to figure out hey
this person know what they're talking
about one other example Matt and this is
not so academic is the dude that was
fired from Google James d'amour for that
memo that he wrote he's appearing
everywhere now as some kind of expert on
everything from gender to you know I
don't know if he's spoken about
post-modernism or whatever but I watched
10 minutes of an interview he did and I
was thinking how is this guy now being
invited to talk about this stuff wasn't
he wasn't he like an IT guy an engineer
of some kind at Google so I know what
you mean but I'm not gonna be the one to
say who shouldn't shouldn't be allowed
to speak you know well can I go
follow-up yeah do you think it's
incumbent on universities or the media
outlets etc to at least provide some
sort of context for what they're
discussing like if for example Brett
Weinstein just to go back to him is
giving a lecture on post-modernism
at least provides some kind of
references or materials for the audience
so they can decide whether she's got a
point or not yeah I mean that's sort of
up to the school I think certainly that
whoever organizes the talk should be
clear about what the credentials are of
the person and then if they don't
include the subject of the discussion
then that should be evident and then the
audience can sort of draw their own
conclusions all right Matt thanks
appreciate the call all right all right
thank you okay very good